there are six questions you must ask
yourself in order for you to position
yourself to dominate an industry and by
the way today's message is not specific
to any industry it can be used for every
single industry out there so let's get
right into it first thing you got to do
wherever you're currently at with your
business what market do you own in your
industry so kind of look at the whole
thing and say well I think we own this
right now I think I want this right now
the thing on this part of the market
right now maybe I want this demographic
or this age or this income or this
country or this state or whatever it is
what is it do you own anything
if not then none but whatever you do
write that down the next one what do you
want to own do you even know what you
want to own is it something where you're
clear about what you want to own is
there an age that you want to own is
there is demographic a culture an income
earner a certain City a certain state a
certain country what market do you want
to own do you know what market that is
that's a second second question got
answered number three who must you
outgun who must you outgun who must you
outdo who is leading this market that
you want to own that you must outgun who
are those people make a list of them ABC
this company here that company here in
this company here by the way this could
be you watching this you to see of
Sprint ok this could be watching this
your billionaire out of Ohio
ok several people that watches value
came in the channel this can be you
saying I want to be Sprint or I want to
be Verizon or AT&T or t-mobile or it
could be your liquor store in you know
Little Rock Arkansas and you want to own
that market in the Little Rock for you
to be the dominant liquor store in
Little Rock March Arkansas but you're
not here who must you outgun and which
market you want to own beer alcohol
vodka whiskey you know wine is it
example what is it that you want to own
right number four enough money how much
money do you need to outgun in order for
you to get the market that you want to
because it takes money it takes money
for marketing for staff for executive
for advertising for technology for speed
for website for you know pay-per-click
it doesn't matter what it is there's
money
you're going to need so how much money
do you currently have to do this and if
you don't have the money how much money
do you need to have in order for you to
be able to do this write that number
down next do you have the
stick-to-itiveness because this is
always fun to do this is very fun to do
people love doing this exercise up to
this point the next one is not that much
fun because most people don't stick to
it mostly or not wanting to stick to it
because this could be 11 years this
could be 13 years this could be 7 years
this can be 24 months people don't think
that long people are like I want it
right now doesn't work that way
this could be a while until you're able
to go out and do this in sports teams
right now I was with Magic Johnson two
weeks ago and I was in am asking a
question and I kind of cornered and one
of the questions that I asked him about
Lakers and he smiled two days later he
announced that his meeting with Jeanie
buss he is now an advisor now Magic
Johnson is trying to recruit Kobe Bryant
to be an advisor because he believes
they can put a team together when the
next two to three years they can be a
championship contender two to three
years he didn't say in the next six
months
too often amateur entrepreneurs want to
write now they need to spend what two
watches what do they currently have
Russell certain athletes what do they
want to have some superstars who do they
need to outgun Cleveland Golden State do
they have enough money yes they do can
they stick to a long thing to be able to
get there yes and last but not least do
you match the position that you want to
have what does that mean for instance
matching the position if I want to
become the best financial advisor in
Silicon Valley and I want to own the
position of people that are in the
technology sector hypothetically okay so
do I match that position to get them do
I look the part do I talk the part do I
walk the part do I go to the places that
they go to the country club that they
belong to the gym the Equinox the Neiman
Marcus do I belong to that special night
club that they go to after hours do I
belong to this do I go do I match that
am i matching that or if I don't care
about that market it's a complete
different market and I'm trying to
connect with the middle America market
do I dress up too preppy am I too much
am I too flashy and I
don't connect with middle America
because middle America is like dude I
wear jeans and shirts and you're over
dressing for me too much and it's kind
of intimidating I've never put a suit on
before and quite frankly I still don't
even know how to tie your tie in you're
trying to give me I don't know about
this guy I don't relate to my don't
connect with them do you match hey I
want to get into the twenty
five-year-old market but I'm 63 years
old how am I going to do it I don't
match how am I going to position myself
to do it once you answer these questions
and you go through it from there if you
can do this and you put a time line to
it the more power to you go get it if
you can do this if you do this and
you're willing to stick around for 2-3
years 7 years 10 years 12 years 15 years
maybe some even 20 years then eventually
you're going to be able to position
yourself to potentially one day dominate
an industry whatever that industry may
be that you want to position to dominate
so with that being said Paul but watch
the pillow this is another short episode
that we did six questions to ask for you
to position yourself to dominate in
industry and if you haven't subscribed
to this channel value tainment yet click
on the button below to subscribe the
notification click the alarm right next
to click on that you'll be part of the
notifications call notifications Squad
is on fire right now love those guys
we're the first to comment on videos if
you got any questions any thoughts
please post your questions on the bottom
and your thoughts on the bottom aside
from that thanks for watching the body
take care go bye
[Music]